[MUSIC PLAYING]
MANO MARKS: Hi, I'm
Mano Marks.
And I'm here with
Brendan Kenny.
And this is the first episode
Google Maps Garage, where
we're going to delve into
technical details on
implementing the Google
Maps API.
So what we often find is that
people are confronted with a
set of common mistakes, common
things that they
do that cause problems.
So you can see, for instance,
if we switch to my laptop
view, you can see, actually,
that right now I am looking at
a blank page.
But if I look at the source code
for the page, it looks
like I have a map.
So the problem here-- this is
probably the most common
mistake that developers make.
The mistake here is that they
don't set the height or width
for the Div that the
map sits in.
So Google Maps needs to be able
to expand the map, to
show the map rather in a Div.
And if the Div itself doesn't
have any height or width, it
won't actually show up.
So you can see here that the
HTML and the body tags are
assigned height, and that
gives them some space.
But the Div itself, the map
canvas Div, has actually has
no height itself.
So this can be fixed
fairly easily.
You can go and in
create a style.
I'm just going to do height
100%, and then you see
the map shows up.
This can be a very frustrating
problem for developers.
There's a related problem
where you give the Div a
height but not the containing
body or not the containing
body element, which means that,
for instance here, this
Div has a width of 100%
and a height of
100%, but there's no--
the body itself doesn't have
any height or width, so the
Div doesn't show up.
So that can also be fixed
by simply giving a
style to the body.
Now, this is one of those
problems that can be really
hard to diagnose.
So I'm going to hand that over
to Brendan, who's going to
show you some tools for
doing some diagnosis.
BRENDAN KENNY: Right.
So if we come back here
to the first example
and undo Mano's fix--
and come back here to
our first example.
So nothing shows up on screen.
And this is in a
lot of feedback
for you as a developer.
You put together
your web page.
Maybe there's a whole bunch of
things going on on the page.
And you just have one Div in the
corner that needs to have
a map in it, and it's
just blank.
And It's really hard to say from
just a blank screen what
exactly is going on.
It could be all sorts
of things.
Maybe your code is not
running it all.
So your number one go-to place
to find out about this stuff
should be the Developer Tools.
So I'm going to be showing
the Chrome Developer
Tools in this case.
But if you use another browser,
most of the major
browsers now have developer
tools that you can use.
So in Chrome, to get access to
them, you come here to the
Options menu and go to
Tools and then down
to Developer Tools.
And that opens up this nice
panel down here at the bottom.
So often, people turn first to
JavaScript alerts, those
ancient devices that pop of
those mobile dialogues and
interrupt everything.
And those are great for
saying a warning
that you cannot ignore.
But it's really annoying for
debugging, especially if you
have like a bunch of alerts
or something like that.
So the next tool people turn
to is console.log.
So that logs to this
screen right here,
the developer console.
And that could be good for
some things, but not for
everything.
So in this case, we actually
have opened up the console.
And at first glance, we can
tell right away there's no
JavaScript errors.
So we know that's not
an issue here.
We still don't know
if our JavaScript
has even run, really.
But let's go take look at
the Elements panel.
And this shows the actual Dom
tree that is used by the
browser to lay out the page.
And so here we see map canvas.
And this was the Div that we
handed to the Maps API and
said fill this up
with your map.
And we can already see there's
a bunch of properties on it
that we didn't add,
so it implies that
something has run here.
And if we open it up, we can see
there's a Div inside and
inside that a whole
bunch of stuff,
which is the map itself.
So what's going on?
The easiest way to tell right
here is that if we highlight
this Div, we can tell up on
the screen up top where it
shows the actual size,
the width and
height of our map Div.
We can tell that it's 2,068
pixels wide and 0 pixels tall.
So that's what's happened.
Our Div is collapsed.
And there's no place for the
map to actually show.
And this just has to do with the
way that Dom elements are
laid out on a page.
A Div, if it doesn't have a
height, either from a height
set on itself or relative to
its positioning within its
parent, it's just going
to have zero height.
And so the map is there.
It just was never given
height, and
so nothing is showing.
And so, as Mano said, we can
just give it a height in our
original document.
And now, if we were refresh, we
can tell that same Div now
has a height that's taken up
the full size of the body.
So if we move to the second
example that Mano showed us,
where we didn't give a size to
the body, but we give it a
size the Div, we can see the
same thing is going on here.
So the map canvas in this case,
we can look over here to
the right and see that it did
indeed have a width and a
height set on it.
But the width and height
are in relative units.
So it's 100% in width and
100% of the height
of its parent container.
And the parent container
is the body element.
And the body itself
has no height.
We can see once again, now it's
1,700 pixels wide and 0
pixels tall.
So once again, we need to
add the height to it.
And at that point, that Div will
then have a height, and
that it won't be an issue.
So yeah, that's our first tool,
is the Developer Tools.
And the Elements pane is really
great for seeing that
page layout sort of thing.
We don't have to worry about
any sort of JavaScript
commands in that case.
We can just kind of explore the
Dom and see why exactly
nothing is showing
up on screen.
Great.
So what if--
I don't have a great segue
to this next one.
MANO MARKS: Segue.
BRENDAN KENNY: Lets try some
different errors, Mano.
MANO MARKS: Yes.
So that is probably--
I'm going to guess,
anecdotally.
It's probably the most common
error that you'll see in
developing a maps application,
and It's one of the more
frustrating ones because--
BRENDAN KENNY: Nothing
shows up.
MANO MARKS: --nothing shows
up, which is why developer
tools are really important.
Another really common problem is
a little different, and I',
going to just show you
what it looks like.
This one actually does give
you back some information.
Here you'll see Google
Maps API server
rejected your request.
The sensor parameters specified
in the request must
be set to either
true or false.
So this happens a lot when
people are copying and pasting
code from our documentation,
because we have to say, set it
to either true or false.
And it must actually be
set to true or false.
So if you take a look here at
this sample, you'll see the
JavaScript loader we
put in this sensor
parameter to the loader.
Now, I'm just going to go
ahead and say this.
You get no benefit
from setting the
sensor to true or false.
It's just a recording mechanism
that we're required
to add on for our
data providers.
And again, by setting the sensor
to true, you don't
actually get a sensor.
All we will say on this is
if you are setting--
if you are using a sensor of
some kind, that is, you are
detecting somebody's location
based on this application,
then you set the
sensor to true.
Otherwise, you set
it to false.
For most use cases that
I've seen, you will be
setting this to false.
It's only if you're doing some
sort of live tracking kind of
application.
So this one is easily fixed.
And you'll see here we set this
to true or, in this case,
I'm going to say false.
And I reload the page.
I'll first dismiss the original
error message.
And there you see
we have a map
OK, so the next one is kind of
similar to that and also will
give you very clear
feedback on it.
The first thing that will happen
is you'll see the map
start to load.
But then you'll see that Google
has disabled the use of
the Maps API for this
application.
The provided key is not a valid
Google API key, blah,
blah, blah.
Basically, that happens when--
again, it often happens when
people are copying and pasting
from the documentation.
And you'll see here we have
the parameter key
equals your API key.
So this is easily solved.
It takes a couple of steps.
But basically, just search on
the Google API console.
And then you'll need to log in
with a Gmail account, and then
you turn on a service
for Google Maps API.
Sorry, you click on API
access, and you
create an API key.
So I'm not going to go through
that in too much detail.
Just search on Google API
console, and then click on
Help to get that.
But the reason that you'd
want to use an API key--
so technically it's optional.
But if you use the API key, you
get slightly higher quotas
on a few of the services,
including the places requests.
And you can then also
track your usage.
In case you have an
extraordinarily popular site
for a very long period of time,
you'll want to be able
to check that to make sure that
your usage is not hitting
up against our usage limits.
So those are the reasons
that you would
want to set that key.
But the key point here is you
may need to actually set a key
and not use our documentation
to copy and
paste your API key.
I'm going to hand this
over to Brendan.
BRENDAN KENNY: So the next
three examples, all have
something in common.
They all leave out a key
parameter to the map
constructor.
So, if we open this up, go to
five, we can see once again
nothing is showing.
But it's slightly different.
You can see that background
color is the
background color of a map.
If you ever noticed that if you
pan too fast and map tiles
haven't loaded yet, this is the
color that's behind them.
So if I go back again, you can
see white is the background.
if you go forward-- so
something's going on.
And so if we open up the
Developer Tools--
so you can use the menu, or you
can be cool and use the
keyboard shortcuts.
That's Command-Option-I or
Control-Option-J, I,
something like that.
Anyway, check your menu
on Windows and Linux.
And so we can see that our
map is plainly here.
If we open it up, down here in
the Elements screen, we can
see all sorts of Dom
elements going on.
So something's happening.
But if we go to our console,
there is no error.
So this is a subtle
bug, another
subtle bug to diagnose.
Because it's not an error, but
the map has not finished being
initialized.
So if we go back to
our code here--
typically, if you've seen this
before, you'll recognize it.
The maps, or the map
constructor, takes a Dom
element to construct in,
and then it also
takes an options object.
And in that options object,
you pass all sorts of
parameters that you want to
use to customize your map.
And there's three
required ones.
You need to set a center of
your view, so a lat/long
coordinate to look at, a zoom
level to base your view on,
and then a map type, whether
that's a road map or a
satellite or other versions
that are at available.
And so in this case, we've
left out the center.
We made it really obvious by
just commenting it out.
And so, as a result, the map
actually has nowhere to look
at, and so that's why it's
not showing anything.
And there's a couple ways
to tell this, that
this is going on.
But the easiest is just to make
sure that all three of
those things are in there.
You can also do something here,
where if I move this
declaration of the map itself
outside of our initialize
function, it makes the map a
global variable, and that way,
I can access it in
the console.
Otherwise, it's lost
inside that scope.
So if I set var.map here, it'll
now be available outside
that function.
And if I go here,
I can see map.
And it is indeed a JavaScript
object.
Yeah, you're big.
OK.
So Map has a bunch of properties
on it and ways of
accessing it.
And so if I say map.getZoom,
for instance, I can see the
zoom level that's currently
going on.
And so at this point, you can
then ask it for the center.
And you can see that
it's undefined.
So this isn't really helpful if
your code is this simple.
You can just look at
your original code.
But say it's within a larger
framework, and everything is
complicated, and you can't tell
what's going on and where
things are initialized.
This can be a great way to go
in and check those three
required things and say,
is this thing defined?
And it turns out, the center
is undefined right now.
And the way the Maps
API works, it's
all this MVC framework.
And so it's all about setting
the state on these models.
And then once the state is set,
it sends messages to go
and actually present
that to the screen.
And in this case, it's waiting
for that center.
And as soon as you set that
center, it's going to be
display it on the screen
and just be a
normal map at that point.
So that's what's going on.
And the reason that it is not
showing anything is because
the way it accelerates
downloading, it actually shows
a really fast view as quickly
as possible before it starts
loading the full tile
view of the map.
And if it had just a default
center view, then it would
always be loading.
It would be quick loading this
view that you don't care about
at all and just wasting
bandwidth and latency.
Especially on mobile, you
have to worry about
that sort of thing.
So map.getCenter is our problem
here, and obviously,
if I uncomment that,
it's not an issue.
So we can see the same
thing over here in
this class of bugs.
So here we've left out Zoom.
And if we do map.getZoom--
oh, I didn't add map to
the global scale.
Well, if I did that
map.getZoom,
it wouldn't be there.
But I didn't move map outside
of this function.
And finally we have this--
we've left out at the
map's typeID.
So this is one that often gets
people, because it's not
something you think about when
you think about, I just want
to show a map.
You think, I need a center.
I need a zoom.
But you don't think that,
oh, I also need to
specify a map type.
But to the Maps API, they're
all equivalent map types.
And so you need to pick one to
represent what you want to
show on the screen.
MANO MARKS: So another common
problem that people have is
they will create a map marker.
And the map marker will not
show up on the map.
And that's--
there's a pretty simple
reason for it.
You look here.
There is you see, hey, I've
created a marker.
But the thing is, in D3 of the
Google Maps API, any overlay
is created independent
of the map.
And then it is assigned
to a particular map.
And the reason for that is so
that the map object itself
doesn't get bloated with
knowledge of where all the
markers are.
Maps API v3 was designed to be
very tight, only downloading
the code that it absolutely
needs for
any individual piece.
So creating the map,
if you just have a
map, you don't need--
it doesn't need to
have knowledge of
where the markers are.
Markers, however, need to know
what map that they go to to.
So in this case, you can
actually do this
in a couple of ways.
You'll see in the options when
you create the marker, you can
just set a map--
you can just set
the map there.
Or you can also set
[AUDIO LOST]
on as a marker.set map.
This is another one that's
not going to show up in--
BRENDAN KENNY: It said map.map
MANO MARKS: Oh, said map.map.
Thank you.
And there you see the map.
The marker shows
up on the map.
This is another one that is not
going to show up well in
Developer Tools, because from
JavaScript's point of view,
there's actually
nothing wrong.
You created this
marker object.
You just didn't do
anything with it.
So again, you could go through
the console and check what its
map property is and figure
out things there.
But fundamentally, it's one of
the things you just have to
know You have to actually put a
marker or any other overlay.
You have to actually
set a map to that.
And then finally, we have
another example here, which is
kind of related to
that problem.
Here, this one will actually
show up in
the console, though.
What often happens is people
will declare the map object in
their initialized function, the
standard way, especially
if you're copying code.
But if you create a separate
function, in this case, you'll
see I created this function
addMarker And then I tell it
to add it to the map.
The mapped object is actually
declared in the initialized
function, so it's out of scope
when I run addMarker.
So this is another point where
declaring the map as a global
variable can be helpful.
Now, there's a lot of discussion
about global
variables and why they're good
and why they're bad.
You should probably check out
a lot of that discussion.
We could have that conversation
at some point.
You typically want to minimize
the number of global variables
because they can interfere
name spacing
with different functions.
And they can just clutter
up your--
you create a lot of global
variables when you're not--
when you don't need them.
But in this case, there are some
distinct advantages to
declaring your map variable as
a global variable there.
BRENDAN KENNY: And there's lots
of other approaches where
you can wrap it up in a name
space or a little module.
And as long as the functions are
within the same module or
have access to that name space,
you can pass around an
object that represents your map,
widget, or whatever, and
keep it out of the global
name space but
still have it available.
Because the Developer Tools
are extremely helpful.
You should learn
to trust them.
And having it available
to the developer
tools is a huge help.
MANO MARKS: I'm actually going
to show you what this looks
like in the Developer Tools, why
these Developer Tools are
so important.
If I take a look at the
JavaScript console, this one
will actually--
you'll see map is not defined.
Now, for somebody who isn't
really paying a lot of
attention, that can be
confusing, because you'll know
you defined the--
you've defined it, and you can
actually click through to
where it's not defined.
And your hint is that it's
in this function.
So that's your scoping
problem.
BRENDAN KENNY: Great.
MANO MARKS: All right.
I think those are the common
problems that we have
for you this time.
We're going to do more episodes
of Maps Garage to
delve into some technical
details.
If you're having any problems
developing your application
with the Google Maps API,
there's a big community of
people on Stack Overflow.
And actually, members of our
team also monitor Stack
Overflow to see what the
problems are that people are
having, and then they can
comment on them there.
So that's your best resource
for getting fast answers to
your questions.
BRENDAN KENNY: We also have a
screencast I did that gives an
introduction to debugging the
Maps API with Dev tools.
It uses some different examples
to just walk through
the Elements pane on your
console, but also the Sources
panel, so you can step
through code.
Well, I guess we'll
link to that.
MANO MARKS: We'll put a link to
that in the YouTube video
description.
BRENDAN KENNY: And then there's
also another Google
Developers Live session called
"The Breakpoint," which
happens periodically --I'm
not sure how often--
that's specifically about the
Chrome Developer Tools.
And those guys are really great,
and you can learn a
lot, so check that out.
MANO MARKS: All right.
I think that's it.
Thank you all for listening
in today, and
hopefully this was helpful.
[MUSIC PLAYING]